I talked to you already about this July
12th national day of action for net
neutrality in the US fewer issues right
now more important in terms of how many
other issues they relate to and impact
and inform and there's different
participating websites that are going to
put up prominent messages about the
FCC's plan to get rid of net neutrality
and it will tell you how to contact
Washington about the issue how to find
your representative etc Netflix used to
be a major player in the fight for net
neutrality during the Obama
administration lobbying activism etc and
a couple weeks ago when I told you about
this day of action I mentioned all of a
sudden Netflix is missing from the big
Internet companies that are on board
with this and Netflix's CEO Reed
Hastings is actually on record recently
as having said quote we think net
neutrality is incredibly important but
not narrowly important to us because we
are big enough to get the deals we want
so rightly people were saying Netflix is
too big for its britches all they care
about is making money they're big enough
to be part of the in rather than the out
but I am pleased to tell you that
Netflix finally has changed their mind
on this and made an announcement a few
days ago via Twitter saying quote
Netflix will never outgrow the fight for
net neutrality everyone deserves an open
Internet now this could be because
Netflix realized oh yeah we do care
about this but it also could be because
it was just bad press not to be a part
of it but either way this is good
Netflix is now fully planning to
participate on the July 12th day of
action to bring attention to what's
going on with net neutrality and a
Netflix spokesperson has put out a
statement now saying quote we support
strong net neutrality protections even
if we are less rat less risk because of
our popularity there are other major
there are other companies for whom this
is a bigger issue and we're joining this
day of action to ensure the next netflix
has a fair shot to go the distance
Amazon is involved reddit is involved
Kickstarter Vimeo Etsy Mozilla OkCupid
imager on and on and on and we know that
people are very engaged in this topic I
told you to leave
ago that the FCC said it received five
million formal written comments on the
matter so I think that there's
definitely a PR and optics angle to
Netflix getting really involved in tis
good no matter what right forgive my
skepticism here though but is it
possible that Netflix will join the
fight but not really be on the front
lines because if net neutrality were to
end then they also kind of win and then
they're trying to have it both ways yeah
I mean your skepticism is logical given
the fact that you know it's 2017 earth
and everything that we know that has
gone on that has gotten us to where we
are today your skepticism makes sense I
still think the net impact is it is good
to have their name on this they are the
most popular video streaming service in
the US but the internet-based video
streaming industry as a whole really
needs net neutrality so if it's if it's
not Netflix they are right that the next
Netflix or some smaller version is that
major risk because of net neutrality
because without net neutrality cable
providers can prioritize cable TV in
ways that can deter people from saying
hey I'll cancel cable because the
Internet video streaming is just as good
that's the risk and that's why this is
so important so in the long run it's
great to have Netflix as involvement
they'll probably also benefit in the
long run I believe it would be way more
effective if these websites didn't work
on July 12 imagine if all of July 12th
from midnight to midnight you go to
Netflix and they have a big thing saying
we need net neutrality call your
representatives we are off in protest of
course a website like Amazon
think about how much money they would
lose if they were to do something like
that it's sort of never going to happen
but that I think is what would be most
impactful here right if Netflix was to
join into that protest then people would
go without entertainment for a day yeah
maybe if a site like Amazon or Google
shut down for a day whole companies
would have to close and that would have
some real financial implications but
maybe that's how you make an impact
right maybe if you say hey look at how
much money is connected to what we are
doing if all of a sudden you've got to
pay $5.99 to be able to stream without
buffering or whatever right I mean it
this is what we're talking about I can't
we overstate the importance of this
enough call your lawmakers go to who is
my representative calm this sort of
appears maybe Pat to be an issue we're
calling your lawmakers might make a tiny
bit of difference on a lot of issues
it's like yeah it's just not changing
campaign finance for example but on net
neutrality there have actually been some
pretty successful public outcry and
protests